We'll use this knowledge of downstream and upstream to help us solve a motion
problem with the current. We know that if we travel downstream we'll end up be
travelling faster since we'll be going with the current. But if we travel
upstream we'll have to be going slower since we're going against it. Let's see
if we can solve this first motion problem together. You take a boat upstream
for ten miles, and then back down for 15 miles. If the speed of the current in
the river is five miles per hour, and you make the entire trip in one hour,
let's see if you can find the speed of the boat in still water. Just like all
the motion problems we've encountered up until this point, we want to use a
table to help us organize all this information. So here's my table and we'll
have the distance for the boat upstream, its rate and its time, and the
distance of the boat downstream with that rate and that corresponding time as
well. We want to find the speed of the boat in still water. So, let's make that
be our variable. X is going to be the speed of our boat and in miles per hour.
So now that we have a variable what expression can you write for the rate, or
the speed of the boat, moving upstream, and the speed of the boat moving
downstream.